the movie opens with a top secret
government run school called Prescott
that trains young orphan girls to be
operatives Hardman is the head of
Prescott and teaches these young girls
to kill he has a number one role no
attachments as it is considered to be a
weakness the girls are number-coded and
are given Fierce training they do not
have any real world experiences and are
only ever taught to fight and kill
number 83 is the best of them all but is
not very convinced about having no
attachments she has always had a
curiosity about the outside world she
outd does everyone in in her class and
gets activated for assignments first
this does not sit well with number 84
who has always been slightly jealous of
her in another scene number 83 is on a
train for a mission to retrieve an
important suitcase she proves to be
successful in doing so the next day on
another mission she notices a group of
people partying and starts to become
curious about it she starts Gathering
Intel on what it is to have a normal
teenage experience she watches movies
and TV shows like Mean Girls Beverly
Hills
9,210 and magazines as a reference point
and is fascinated with that lifestyle in
the next scene Hardman introduces an
arms dealer Victoria Knox undercover in
chetna and assigns 83 to capture her 84
shows her disagreement saying it should
have been her assignment Hardman
instantly rejects her saying she is only
the B Team Knox is frustrated and feels
left out again during the operation Knox
and her team are confronting three
masked people to her surprise one of
them is 83 a fight scene breaks out
between the two during the fight 83 men
manages to latch herself and knocks onto
an oncoming jet with Hardman on it when
they get high and far enough 83 drops
herself into a river while the other
agents apprehend knocks they keep trying
to reach out to her but she makes the
decision to run and have the normal life
she has always dreamed about after they
find no sign of 83 she is declared Mia
83 goes into hiding to start her new
life as a regular teenager she adopts
the name Megan Walsh and starts looking
for a family to host her as a foreign
exchange student she finds the Larson
family and Newton USA the lson family
has three members Mrs lson and her
children Les and Parker the son
instantly likes Megan but the daughter
appears to be cold and distant towards
her later at the dinner table she finds
out that Mrs lson is recently divorced
they get into introducing each other and
getting familiar Parker tells 83 that he
wants to be a ninja she tells the family
about how excited she is to join high
school and experience normal things like
riding on a bus Liz finds the excitement
over a bus ridiculous and quite weird
for her first day at school Megan picks
a ridiculous outfit for school and is
immediately laughed at Liz gets
embarrassed and gives her new clothes to
put on she tells her to not make the
experience of high school any worse than
it already is during the assembly the
Headmaster of the school welcomes the
students as 83 Waits her turn to be
introduced in the assembly backstage she
meets a geeky boy named Roger he appears
to instantly develop a crush on her the
principal calls her onto the stage she
introduces herself as Megan Walsh from
Regina Canada but she pronounces it to
rhyme with vagina all the students laugh
and she feels humiliated surprisingly
the school's most popular guy cash goes
up to play his guitar and sings to save
her from embarrassment he then performs
on stage with his band iMat Aken as
Megan continues her new life as a high
school student she makes friends with
Roger who has an interest in her but she
is attracted to the singer boy cash she
finds out she's in a biology class with
him and hacks the teacher's seating
system to make him her lab partner this
makes the two Mean Girls of the class
angry and jealous as retaliation the
girls convince Megan that cash loves
girls with school spirit and suggests
she try out for the position of school
mascot she uses her combat skills in her
triy out to get the position to become
the mascot she gets it as she is the
only candidate for it at the game she
shows full enthusiasm in her role as the
school's mascot but then a few kids from
a rival School come and try to kidnap
Megan not knowing that it is a part of a
tradition she beats them thinking they
are the agents coming for her after that
Roger tries to console her but it has no
effect on Megan back home she is
frustrated about how difficult High
School is but Mrs Larsson gives some
motherly advice to her Dak at Prescott
Hardman is holding Knox in captivity he
tries to reason with her but it goes in
vain 84 walks in on them as Knox tells
Hardman that Prescott destroys lives and
she's not just talking about the targets
meanwhile at the school Megan's video of
berating those kids that the fame goes
viral she walks in and everybody starts
praising her even gu the class clown her
new popularity annoys Liz she tells her
that she is not buying her whole deal
and that she is watching her cash starts
taking an interest in Megan and invites
her to his Jam sessions at the session
she finds Roger helping out with the
sound system she tells him that she
doesn't like to be on the internet and
likes to lie low just as they are
starting to bond cash and his band walk
in and take Megan away that makes Roger
sad after a while cash invites her to a
house party as she's walking home she is
apprehended by a Prescott analyst and is
brought back to Hardman he is ready to
have his minion Pedro torture Megan
under the assumption that she is working
with enemies of Prescott he injects her
with a truth serum and realizes she is
honest when she says she only wants to
enjoy a normal life outside the academy
Pedro also sympathizes with her as she
cries Hardman tells her that she cannot
go Rogue and needs to come with them
immediately she asks him to give her
some time to tie the Loose Ends Hardman
lets her go they dump her on the front
porch of the Larsen house to make Megan
look like she's super drunk Liz goes and
helps her out reluctantly a few scenes
later Megan and Liz both attend a big
party at the home of the school's Class
Clown gu at the party Megan continues to
hang out with cash to her surprise 84 is
there now going by Heather both go into
the bathroom and have a heated
discussion Megan thinks Hardman sent her
to keep an eye out but she has her own
plan Brewing meanwhile Liz gets drunk
with guc in his bathtub learning that
his name is really Bernard and that he's
not a total jerk back at the party
Heather goes after cash to piss Megan
off they both compete with each other
for his attention Roger comes to the
party and finds Megan kissing cash he
gets hurt and leaves the party she gets
invited to go for breakfast with the fun
gang and finds Liz drunk and sleeping on
the couch but instead of being with her
she goes off with other people in the
morning Mrs Larsson is furious with both
the girls for being irresponsible she
scolds Megan for leaving her friend
drunk and not bringing her home straight
she tells her that her family doesn't do
that and asks her to do better while
waiting for the school bus Megan notices
that the bus driver is none other than
Hardman he tells her that KNX has
escaped Prescott and shows her the video
where she threatens to kill her he urges
her to come with him but she refuses
Hardman warns her that if she doesn't
come with him that means she is all on
her own she accepts the terms and goes
on her own way later she takes the ride
to school in lizz's car in the car both
of them are arguing about the party when
a mysterious black van starts shooting
at them scared and confused Liz loses
control Megan asks her to switch seats
with her they are now in a thrilling car
chase in all the haste she tells Liz the
truth about her identity the car chase
gets heated and she crashes their car
crashing at the Assassin as well she
suspects that 84 is the one who chased
her Liz gets injured at the hospital she
calls Hardman to confront him about why
he sent 84 to almost kill her he tells
her that he didn't and thought that 84
got killed during the knox's Escape
worried she asks him to help him but he
refuses to do so she goes to lizz's room
where she is admitted she tells her that
she is going to leave because she
doesn't want anyone else to get hurt but
Liz tells her that abandoning people is
not the way you love people and asks her
to stay with them Megan steps out of the
room for a while and when she returns
she finds Liz and Goose making out after
Liz gets healed both of them prepare to
protect themselves from KNX they both
start bonding with each other over a
discussion of an agent's life Mrs Larson
finds relief and happiness seeing that
both of them are finally on good terms
the homecoming dance arrives they both
get ready to go to the dance with goose
and cash at the party Megan realizes
that cash is kind of a boring person and
dumps him she realizes that Roger is the
one who has always found her interesting
she goes to apologize to him who is
still sort of upset with her and then
she finds out that his date is Heather
she provokes Megan's rage and they fight
in the party during the fight they spill
drinks on the Mean Girls Who then start
to fight each other Heather chases Megan
into the hallway where they end up in
the kitchen she says she joined Knox for
the chance to kill Megan herself she
also brags about making out with cash
and Roger Liz sneaks up on Heather and
stabs her in the leg with a corn dog
stick allowing Megan to whack Heather
over the head and knock her out Megan
returns home to find that Knox and some
goons have taken Parker and Mrs Larsson
hostage she fights the goons but Liz
also gets captured as well Knox reveals
that she was Prescott agent one but she
left and turned against them for robbing
her of her life both Megan and Knox get
into a fight and it is revealed that
Knox was the first Prescott girl then in
a Twist of events Hardman shows up with
reinforcements to take out the goons and
tranquilize KNX happy to see him she
tells her that she always knew he would
come to rescue her she tells him that
despite his rule of having no
attachments he cares about her she goes
on to hug him Parker asks him if he can
join Prescott as he has always dreamed
of becoming a ninja Hardman tells him to
apply for Prescott school for boys he
excitedly asks his mom if he can she
hesitates and tells him they'll talk
about it later then Hardman asks Liz and
Megan to go and finish their homecoming
dance while handing them the keys to a
helicopter in the final scene both the
girls take the helicopter to where Roger
is Megan asks him to forgive her and
give her a chance Roger agrees and hugs
her both the girls along with their
boyfriends go on a ride on the
helicopter and the movie
[Music]
ends